les obsèques du président boumédiène
d'alger plusieurs centaines de milliers
de personnes ont assisté à l'enterrement
l'iran nouvelles émeutes à téhéran l'un
des leaders de l'opposition accepte de
former un gouvernement
football stade de reims dépose son bilan
pour l'instant le club continue la
saison en championnat
la saison de ski nouvelle station contre
village traditionnel l'exemple de
valloire
bonsoir
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
personnes dans les rues d'alger
aujourd'hui pour le dernier adieu à
houari boumédiène le président algérien
dans la dépouille mortelle était exposé
depuis mercredi au palais du peuple a
été inhumé cet après midi aux côtés de
l'émir abdelkader les obsèques qui se
sont déroulées en présence des
dignitaires du régime algérien et des
délégations étrangères dans un climat
d'intense émotion
en sortant du palais du peuple l'ex
palais d'été le cercueil du président
boumédiène a été chargé sur un affûts de
canon tirés par un véhicule blindé
couvert de fleurs à l'intérieur duquel
ont pris place des officiers
représentant les 3 ha en longeant le
bord de mer le convoi prend tout d'abord
la direction de la grande mosquée
d'alger
cérémonie brève et sans aucun protocole
le cercueil du président boumédiène est
posée à même le sol et l'imam récite la
prière de l'absent la prière des morts
dans la liturgie musulmane cérémonie se
termine par la phrase rituelle répétait
en choeur par l'assistance
allah akbar dieu est grand
c'est au sortir de la mosquée que tout à
coup une marée humaine surtout composé
de jeunes adolescents jusqu alors retenu
par des milliers de policiers de soldats
en armes des bords de service d'ordre
pour approcher une dernière fois le
président défunt on assiste alors à des
scènes d'hystérie collective dans la
plus grande tradition arabe et le convoi
funéraire se trouve complètement bloqué
pendant plus d'une demi heure dans la
pagaille indescriptible ministre du
gouvernement sont même obligés de
quitter le cortège pour couper à travers
la ville et ne le rattrape et que
quelques kilomètres plus loin pour se
frayer un chemin les autorités
militaires font appel aux pompiers qui
prennent la tête du convoi dégageant la
foule à coup de lances d'incendié
enfin le cercueil du président peut
reprendre son périple à travers la ville
pour gagner le cimetière d'el alia à une
dizaine de kilomètres de la capitale
après la tempête le silence imposant du
cimetière d'el alia au son des
roulements de tambour rythmant la marche
lente des soldats de la garde
présidentielle
le cercueil de houari boumédiène suivi
par monsieur rabah bitat le président
par intérim et les principaux
personnages de l'état est amené jusqu'au
carré des martyrs où il reposera aux
côtés des héros de l'algérie comme
l'émir abdelkader et le glorieux
combattants de la révolution didouche
mourad
le dernier salut de l'armée à l'un des
siens minute de recueillement et dernier
hommage des personnalités du monde
entier venus assister aux obsèques du
président algérien au premier rang
monsieur rabah bitat président par
intérim bouteflika ministre des affaires
étrangères derrière eux le président
syrien assad
yasser arafat le leader palestinien
monsieur françois poncet ministre des
affaires étrangères français et beaucoup
d'autres
ses funérailles nationales les algériens
se sont aperçus qu'en réalité c'était
les premières de leur histoire et cela
est vrai c'est le premier président de
la république que l'algérie en terre le
premier responsable d'un et algériens
conçu dans les vastes frontières du
colonialisme du sahara à la méditerranée
ses funérailles pensent certains
algériens seront le ciment qui permettra
de sceller définitivement l'unité
territoriale de l'algérie au delà des
antagonismes technique comédienne
s'était efforcé de réaliser cette unité
et c'est un des points capital de son
testament politique
autre point important la politique
étrangère l'algérie a une position
géographique stratégique économique qui
intéresse la sécurité de la méditerranée
occidentale et donc de l'europe
révolutionnaire tourner plutôt vers
l'union soviétique
vous me viennent avec des hauts et des
bas maintenait tout de même un équilibre
entre l'est et l'ouest
il effrayé pourtant les occidentaux et
au sein du monde arabe et de l'afrique
les modérés pour certains les
réactionnaires pour d'autres d'ailleurs
et cela est très significatif à ses
obsèques
sur le plan des représentations au
niveau international il n'y a que les
responsables arabes du front du refus
comme le président syrien assad où
yasser arafat
ce n'est pas beaucoup mais aussi à
travers cela on sent bien que la
préoccupation des chancelleries
internationale est de savoir quelle sera
la politique extérieure que suivront le
ou les successeurs de boumédiène je
rappelle que demain à 11h 45 antenne 2
va diffuser une émission spéciale d'une
demi heure consacrée aux obsèques du
président algérien
ce sera un résumé de ces cérémonies
officielles commenté par daniel bilalian
est destiné plus particulièrement aux
centaines de milliers de travailleurs
algériens qui résident en france demain
donc
11h45 à 12h15 sur antenne 2 2e grands
titres de l'actualité de ce soir l'iran
toujours en état des meutes permanente
alors qu'il est d'ailleurs les
manifestations nocturnes continuent dans
les rues de téhéran
les accrochages entre l'armée et les
manifestants auraient déjà fait entre 5
et 10 morts cet après midi il ya eu
également des manifestations dans les
provinces et puis les grèves continuent
dans pratiquement tous les secteurs
nomique bref on a affaire un pays qui
avance lentement vers le chaos
et on voit mal encore pour l'instant ce
que pourra changer la décision de
monsieur bakhtiar l'un des leaders du
front national la principale opposition
politique au chat qui a accepté cet
après-midi le principe de former un
nouveau gouvernement
manifestation à mashhad ou tabriz
téhéran des dizaines de morts après des
heurts avec l'armée ce soir plus que
jamais l'iran est au bord du chaos
la loi martiale n'y fait plus rien les
manifestants sont de plus en plus
nombreux et s'en prennent chaque jour
davantage aux installations américaines
conséquence les américains quittent en
masse le pays tandis que de son côté le
gouvernement néerlandais a déjà mis au
point un plan d'évacuation pour tous ses
ressortissants
autant dire qu'après deux mois de grève
et de manifestation ou clavier
économique du pays est paralysé le
système bancaire est proche de
l'effondrement
l'inflation est galopante et ce qui est
encore plus inquiétant la paralysie des
transports commence à créer de sérieux
problèmes d'approvisionnement alors que
faute de fioul domestique les usines
ferment leurs portes
les grévistes du secteur pétrolier
justement ont fait connaître leurs
exigences aujourd'hui pour une reprise
du travail
1 l'ensemble de la production doit être
réservé à la consommation intérieure
deux des représentants des grévistes
doivent surveiller l'application de
cette mesure
3 enfin les exportations doivent être
totalement suspendu et notamment vers
israël dans ce climat d'anarchie
un homme a pourtant accepté aujourd'hui
de former un nouveau gouvernement
il s'appelle chapour bakhtiar il fait
partie du front national d'opposition
mais déjà l'ensemble de son parti l'a
désavoué ce qui devrait logiquement le
conduire à refuser cette tâche si l'on
s'en réfère tout au moins aux
déclarations qu'il faisait il ya tout
juste une semaine
ecoutez-le au problème pour nous c'est
le problème de ce que vous entendez par
la coalition que j'appartiens au front
national
et comme membre de s'offre engin peut
participer qu'avec l'autorisation du
front national
je pense que de plus en plus on parle en
iran mais d'après ce que j'entends d'un
conseil de régence ce conseil de régence
et légiférera enfin à un remplacera le
roi pendant deux ans en attendant que le
prince héritier arrive à sa majorité
c'est la solution que j'entends le plus
parmi les diverses personnalités
actuellement en mode
de leur côté les états unis ont décidé
d'accélérer la mise au point des
dispositifs d'urgence d'évacuation de
leurs ressortissants
malgré de nombreux départs ces dernières
semaines 35 mille américains sont encore
présents en iran en ce moment il est
même question que le président carter
envoie dans le golfe persique
un porte-avions et plusieurs navires de
la 7e flotte paul nahon première
question à quoi peuvent bien servir ces
navires américains
oui tout d'abord il faut dire qu'il est
tout à fait habituelle le camp période
de troubles graves dans un pays même
lointain où les intérêts menacés
américains sont menacés c'est le cas en
iran il est tout à fait habituel normal
que les américains que washington envoie
toute une série de porte-avions de deux
navires croiser au large des côtes du
pays en question alors dans un deux un
double but vous l'avez dit d'abord
rapatriés s'il le faut les
ressortissants américains ils sont très
nombreux dressent encore très nombreux
en iran ils sont 35 milles et d'autre
part c'est important rassurer si vous
voulez psychologiquement le gouvernement
question le gouvernement du chat en
l'occurrence en liant mais n'est
absolument pas question d'après les
américains que ses troupes américaines
qui vont rester sur les bateaux sur les
porte-avions interviennent militairement
et ponctuellement en dire alors
deuxième question paul nahon est ce
qu'on peut dire si les états unis
continuent de soutenir totalement ce
soir le tchadien
oui je crois qu'il faut être très précis
sur ce point même si en privé les
américains reconnaissent ce cas plus ou
moins brève échéance le régime la chute
du chah est inéluctable
officiellement le président carter
lui-même continue de soutenir le champ
alors pourquoi tout simplement et on l'a
dit plusieurs fois parce que l'iran est
une pièce maîtresse du dispositif
américain dans le monde mais surtout les
américains ne voit pas pour l'instant de
solution de remplacement d' alternative
si vous voulez origines du chat car ils
le disent très franchement
d'après nos contacts avec toute
l'opposition iranienne celle ci n'a pas
de programme réellement cohérent n'a pas
de politique de rechange acceptable
nous les etats-unis et puis les
américains reconnaissent aussi qui se
sont lourdement trompé sur l'analyse de
la situation depuis longtemps et que
c'est la première fois réellement la
première fois dans leur histoire qu'ils
ont à faire face à une situation aussi
rationnel c'est à dire un homme le shaq
une très grande partie de la population
condamne qui ne veut pas laisser la
place et une opposition d'après the
totalement stérile et un enjeu aussi
fera de toute façon la situation semble
encore ce soir totalement bloqué
dernière question paul nahon le problème
de l'ayatollah khomeiny qui est encore
en france il a demandé que relever les
manches de son visa elles ont valu à
cordoue il est très probable qu'on
donnera l'autorisation l'ayatollah
communique de séjourner en france pour
des raisons évidentes que tout le monde
comprendra qui sait de quoi demain sera
fait en iran c'est aujourd'hui officiel
le système monétaire européen ne prendra
pas effet le 1er janvier comme cela
était prévu c'est un problème soulevé
par la france qui a entraîné ce retard
celui des montants compensatoires une
sorte de prime à l'exportation qui
pénalise entre autres les agriculteurs
français et que la france voudrait voir
disparaître
monsieur mais heinrich dans notre
journal hier à 20h nous l'avait expliqué
le premier ministre l'a confirmé
aujourd'hui le système monétaire
européen n'entrera pas en vigueur tant
qu'une solution satisfaisante ne sera
pas trouvée
c'est essentiellement un problème franco
allemand il pourrait se régler dès le 4
janvier avec une réunion des ministres
de l'agriculture européenne ou mieux les
5 et 6 janvier à la guadeloupe puisque
en marge du sommet valéry giscard
d'estaing et helmut schmidt aborderont
sans aucun doute ce problème autre
voyage prévu pour le président de la
république d'ici à la fin du mois de
janvier douze jours après la guadeloupe
monsieur giscard d'estaing lira en
visite officielle en roumanie
à l'invitation du président ceausescu
enfin pour en terminer avec l'étranger
sachez que monsieur adolfo suarez le
président du gouvernement espagnol va
s'adresser dans une heure à peu près à
la télévision espagnole pour expliquer
sa décision de dissoudre le parlement
élu le 15 juin 1977
c'était l'une des possibilités offertes
par la nouvelle constitution qui est
entré en vigueur aujourd'hui la nouvelle
élection générale pourrait se dérouler
dans le courant du mois de mars
les problèmes de la natalité maintenant
hier jean paul 2 condamnait
solennellement l'avortement devant des
médecins italiens
dans le même temps nous vous en parlions
d'ailleurs dès hier soir le mensuel
enfant magazine publié en france publie
un sondage réalisé par l'institut louis
harris sur les désirs de maternité des
françaises et il apparaît dans ce
sondage que si 85% des français sont
désireuses d'avoir des enfants
seuls 34% d'entre elles souhaitent en
avoir trois ou plus dans un couple il y
a les enfants que l'on souhaite
et puis il y a les enfants qui naissent
parfois entre les deux il ya bien des
surprises
et je pense aux familles qui du jour au
lendemain parce de deux trois quatre
cinq ou même six membres
et oui ça arrive parfois des naissances
multiples et cela n'arrive qu'aux autres
dit on souvent
en fait non cela peut arriver parfois
aux femmes traitées pour des cas de
stérilité exemple madame dosogne que
monique atlan a rencontré autrefois pour
les femmes stériles
aucune alternative elle était à fait
content pour toujours aujourd'hui
certaines d'entre elles celles qui sont
dans l'incapacité de libérer chaque mois
à nos bulles peuvent grâce à des
injections d'hormones avoir des enfants
mais cela ne passe qu'un vite j'ai
d'abord su que j'avais deux à quinze
jours de grossesse tout quinze jours
trois semaines de grossesse la soirée
des jumeaux quinze jours plus tard
l'annoncé des prix plaît ça un triplé
s'est très bien passé les jumeaux s'est
très bien passé puisque l'état de change
des triplés s'est très mal passé as tu
un jour de prison
nerveux parce qu'il me semblait que je
n'ai plus une femme
marc quelque chose d'étrange avons
travaillé et que j'avais jamais allé à
les porter ça c'est trop et puis quand
jours après donc un oeuf semaine on m'a
dit que j'avais une cale me plaît voilà
je crois que j'ai éclaté de rire parce
que c'était tellement étonnant enfin bon
et si c'était parce que incroyable avant
qu'un bébé là qu en fait et après
beaucoup je crois je n'ai plus voulu
retourner à ses échographies et c'est
par échographie qu'on détermine le
nombre de bébés parce que j'ai tellement
peur manon 5 6 1 jeudi à cas c'est fini
je ne retourne plus haut si c'était à
refaire
si c'était à refaire si si je n'avais
pas cela je ferais vous et un traitement
met en avant aussi et c'est à la fois
une joie d avoir tous les cas parce que
c'est amusant ces îles sont ils sont
très drôles et c'est à la fois une
déception parce que je n'aurais jamais
plus de dt et on peut pas et on crée de
la frustration
on ne peut pas avoir les cadres des
débats soit toute la journée il ya des
jours où je me sens bien et je n'ai pas
vu que je n'ai pas mourir jeune et avec
qui je n'ai pas joué
j'ai joué avec un autre et alors je vais
vraiment allant de la prestation ses
traitements contre la stérilité ne sont
donc pas sans faille
de plus en plus utilisés pas toujours
maîtrisé ils sont quand même défendue
par les gynécologues
grâce à ces médicaments qui viennent
copier presque parfaitement le cycle
physiologique naturelles elles peuvent
avoir un enfant nous faisons ovules et
véritablement un acte magique car on
décide du jour de l'ovulation de la
femme avec une piqûre alors dans 30% des
cas on dépasse le but et il y a non pas
une ovulation mais deux trois quatre ou
cinq saisons extrêmement difficile de
savoir comment manipuler fait
médicaments et il faut accepter le
risque un risque oui mais les
spécialistes qui prennent en charge ces
enfants toujours prématuré avec les
difficultés que cela comporte sont
nettement plus nuancées
les femmes qui se font traiter pour
stérilité ne sont pas toujours bien
averti du risque qu'elles courent le
risque qu'il est le suivant non
seulement elles peuvent avoir des
jumeaux maîtres peut avoir des tripes et
des quadruplés même des quintuplés et à
l'heure actuelle il ya un certain nombre
de femmes qui je le sais me l'ont dit si
elle avait été dûment prévenues attend
aurait demandé l'avortement donc il faut
respecter la liberté de la femme dans
cette affaire c'est d'ailleurs pour vous
dire que dans l'esprit du public toutes
sortes d'idées se forme
il ya des personnes qui m'écrivent pour
me demander comment maintenant on peut
avoir des jumeaux parce qu'il ya des
médecins qui sont à la limite du
charlatanisme qui font prévoir à leur
femme que effectivement avec un peu de
chance avec leurs clientes qui lient
leur donneront des jumeaux des triplés
alors vous voyez là il ya un abus de
confiance extraordinaire
avoir quatre enfants en même temps c'est
évidemment multiplier tous les problèmes
tout bbc 750 couches par mois 75 litres
de lait des centaines de petits pots et
pour la mer un emploi du temps militaire
pour la famille un problème immédiat de
logement et les difficultés ne font
qu'augmenter avec l'âge des enfants
cette somme tout petit sur main on a
quand même beaucoup de travail mais à ce
moment là beaucoup plus de sous
c'est à dire pour tous pour l'école pour
tous pour les habiller pour pouvoir s'en
fout voilà on est gris appel demandant
est tout à fait de très jolis laird en
nous félicitant mais personne ne fait
rien voilà l'histoire est là
alors devant c'est indifférent que j'ai
les roms ces victimes très particulière
de la médecine
sauf à se regrouper pour s'entraider et
surtout pour obtenir l'aide financière
que l'état n'a pas encore jugé vous ne
leur accorder dans le dossier social de
cette fin de semaine sachez qu'une grève
générale est prévue en lorraine le 12
janvier prochain elle sera organisée par
les syndicats de la sidérurgie et du
textile qui veulent protester contre les
suppressions d'emplois
la crise de l'opéra de paris une
manifestation de protestation des
employés de l'opéra et de certains
théâtres parisiens ce matin avenue de
l'opéra et puis dans la soirée les
machinistes ont décidé d'assurer les
représentations prévues pour demain du
lac des cygnes
le public pourra donc enfin admirer
rudolf noureev dans ce ballet enfin pour
en terminer avec la rubrique spectacle
et social il y aura une grève aux folies
bergère le soir du 31 décembre des
problèmes d'emploi et deux grosses ou
maintenant mais en football avec la
situation financière du stade de reims
ce n'est pas très brillant à tel point
que le club a été mis officiellement
aujourd'hui en règlement judiciaire
il n'est pas encore question de voir
disparaître des stades le fameux maillot
rouge amende à manches blanches qui
avait fait les beaux jours du football
français de 1949 à 1962 car le stade de
reims va terminer sa saison mais
certains professionnels risquent fort de
se retrouver au chômage
les faits thierry roland le stade de
reims le club le plus prestigieux du
football français de ces dernières
années et en règlement judiciaire voilà
la triste nouvelle que les amateurs de
football ont appris alors qu'il
s'apprêtait à passer en famille les
fêtes de fin d'année profitant d'une
trêve bien gagner un juge commissaire a
été nommé par le tribunal de commerce de
la ville de reims ainsi que deux syndics
qui auront à étudier la possibilité de
la poursuite de l'exploitation du stade
de reims et il n'est malheureusement pas
exclu que le stade de reims et du mal à
finir la saison
reims c'est avec saint-etienne la plus
belle carte de visite du football
français de l'après-guerre
souvenez-vous le grand stade de reims
des années 50 deux finales de coupe
d'europe sept titres de champion deux
coupes de france le doublé
coupe-championnat en 58 la grande année
du football français comment at-on pu en
arriver là
les responsabilités sont multiples
souhaitons que les choses puissent
s'arranger
encore que le président bazelaire ou son
joueur actuel camara n'est pas la même
vue du problème qui secoue le football
français en cette période de fêtes
je pense que oui nous allons de toute
façon nous allons continuer le
championnat alors continuer mais il est
certain que quand on a nous nous sommes
adressés aux joueurs pour leur demander
une collaboration pour leur demander je
voulais dit la dernière fois de
participer au rendement du club et
peut-être de perdre aussi un petit peu
d'argent car ce que l'ennemi qu'il faut
prononcer léger j'ai reçu un refus total
de la part des joueurs et c'était jeudi
une des grandes déceptions depuis que je
suis au stade de reims qu'est ce qui va
se passer vous et les licenciés les
joueurs mais nous allons prendre des
décisions dans les jours qui viennent
il est certain que ce qu'on assiste
effectivement d'un syndic qui va
collaborer avec nous je le présume et
dans les meilleures conditions
le conseil d'administration dans cette
temps sa totalité a décidé justement ce
dépôt de bilan ce qui nous facilite les
choses car les joueurs qui ne veulent
pas chez nous se battre comme il devrait
le faire et qui s'y sont je le dis bien
qu'ils ont été recrutés avec pour avoir
un certain talent et qu'ils n'ont pas et
qui ne se battent pas eh bien non rien à
faire chez nous comment expliquer que le
garçon avant de venir à reims il est bon
harass il fait plus rien il repart de
reims il est bon il ya quelque chose
bon je n'attaquerai personne mais je dis
ça me fait mal au coeur et c'est triste
l'olympique de marseille autres clubs de
football qui connaît des difficultés
financières a plus de chance lui son
président monsieur d'agostino a révélé
aujourd'hui que la municipalité de
marseille venait d'accorder au club
une avance exceptionnelle de 100
millions de centimes pas d'accord pour
dingo un député communiste du nord
monsieur âge s'étonne que l'on utilise
dingo le compagnon de mickey dans les
bandes dessinées de walt disney sur
l'emblème de l'équipe de france aux jeux
olympiques de 1980 dingo dit le député
est considéré aux états unis comme le
symbole de la réussite par l'argent ce
qui n'est pas très compatible avec la
réussite avec la réussite olympique oui
mais de plus d'1 go la plupart du temps
est présentée sous des travers ridicule
les athlètes françaises ne doivent pas
lui être associés monsieur h demande
donc à jean pierre soisson quel sera son
dessin
les douaniers de l'aéroport de roissy en
verve aujourd'hui à leur actif une
première saisie de deux kilos 600
grammes de cocaïne valeur 130 millions
de centimes
un trafiquant italien qui venait du
pérou où il avait caché avait caché la
drogue dans une valise à double fond et
puis en fin de matinée 800 grammes de
cannabis et 600 grammes d'opium valeur
un million et demi de centimes
un couple qui revenait d'inde les
douaniers de l'aéroport de bogota en
colombie ont fait encore mieux puisque
en une semaine depuis le 20 décembre ils
ont saisi 97 kg de cocaïne
l'actualité de ce vendredi 29 décembre
il ya aussi cet accident d'avion à
portland dans l'orégon aux états unis il
y a dix morts c'est un véritable miracle
qu'il n'y en ait pas eu davantage qu'il
n'y ait pas eu davantage de victimes car
l'appareil s'est écrasé près d'un
quartier résidentiel de la ville
toutes proportions gardées c'est en
effet pour les témoins un véritable
miracle qu'il n'y ait pas eu plus de
victimes dans cet accident
l'appareil un dc-8 de la compagnie
américaine united airlines dont le train
d'atterrissage et les réacteurs ne
fonctionnait plus a rebondi sur un
terrain vague à deux pas d'une rue très
passante d'un quartier résidentiel de
portland au milieu d'un nuage de fumée
et de jets de carburant il a tout
arraché sur son passage arbres et lignes
électriques pour s'écraser finalement
contre deux maisons heureusement vide
il est incroyable dans ces conditions
que l'avion n'est pas pris feu et qu'il
n'y ait eu aucune victime au sol deux
passagers n'ont pas été retrouvés
l'un d'eux un prisonnier évadé que les
policiers ramené à son pénitencier a
sans doute profité de la confusion pour
s'échapper à nouveau
début d'un long week-end pour ces
vacances du nouvel an pour ce long
week-end du nouvel an avec le réveillant
alors je me tourne maintenant vers
laurent broomhead notre spécialiste de
la météo
laurent vous allez affiner vos
prévisions pour ce week-end oui et quand
je vous le disais hier bien le temps
doux n'est pas éternel et des deux mains
et vient des dimanches pardon le froid
reviendra sur le nord du pays alors
demain d'abord beaucoup de nuages avec
quelques pluies par moments de la
bretagne à la flandre sur le reste du
pays un temps variable avec des nuages
et quelques éclaircies
une bande de pluie traversera le pays
d'ouest en ouest d'abord le matin sur
l'atlantique puis sur le massif central
et les pyrénées 2 places c'est pour
samedi dimanche maintenant et bien
toujours sur la france ce même temps
médiocre avec des nuages et quelques
éclaircies et des averses
mais dans la journée sur la moitié nord
le vent qui pour l'instant souffle de
l'ouest tourner oral à l'est et dès lors
le l'air froid qui pour l'instant
circuit de la scandinavie au groenland
envahira le nord du pays les
températures baisseront de 7 à 9 degrés
et la neige fera son apparition même on
va à basse altitude et logiquement
vraisemblablement ce froid on verra tout
le pays
les jours suivants pour la gerard et
alors en vous restez avec nous parce que
l'on a appris dans la soirée qu'il y
avait de l'orage dans l'air sur vénus
sont les savants soviétique qui nous ont
informés alors vous êtes notre
spécialiste météo mais vous étudiez
aussi souvent ces problèmes
scientifiques comment est-ce que vous
expliquer ses coups de tonnerre sur
vénus est bien la sonde soviétique
vénéra 12 en traversant l'atmosphère de
l'étoile du berger le 21 décembre en
effet détecté de violente décharge
électrique suivie d'un fort grondement
bref un orage alors sur terre et bien
lorsque des gouttelettes de pluie sont
aspirés vers le haut dans les gros
nuages d'orage
chaque gouttelette d'eau et en
électriser il se crée entre le haut et
le bas du nuage une sorte de pile
lorsque la tension électrique est trop
forte a déchargé de plaque scellée clair
sur vénus donc nous voyons ici une
animation
l'atmosphère est quatre fois plus
épaisse il est donc a priori logique
qu'un phénomène similaire s'y produisent
en revanche sous ces nuages pas de pluie
en effet la température du sol à plus de
400 degrés valoriserait les gouttes
d'eau qui voudraient s'y approcher voilà
en tout cas de quoi faire réfléchir les
astronomes français qui se propose
d'envoyer en 1983 là bas un ballon pour
étudier les vents on savait déjà que
vénus c'est une serre que dans son ciel
circulent des nuages d'acide sulfurique
voilà qu'en plus elle
et électrique c'est vraiment l'enfer
bien toutes ces précisions sont notés
vers maintenant pour terminer ce journal
parlé des vacances à la neige et des
vacances en particulier aux sports
d'hiver
vous savez que de plus en plus de
français vont faire du ski chaque année
et vous devez savoir évidemment que cela
ne manque pas de poser des problèmes à
ceux qui habitent la montagne lorsqu'il
s'agit d'aménager les stations de sports
d'hiver
un grand débat s'est ouvert d'ailleurs à
ce propos grandes polémiques parfois
entre certains promoteurs partisans des
nouvelles stations créées
artificiellement ou non au pied des
pistes en altitude
et puis les montagnards qui préfèrent
peut rester maîtres de leur montagne
tout en accueillant les touristes
la nouveauté face à la tradition le
débat n'est pas nouveau mais avaloirs
station village de savoie entre chambéry
et grenoble
on a d'ores et déjà choisi une enquête
de gérardmer rigaud station-village
valloire a su allier la nécessité
d'exploiter le tourisme sans perdre pour
autant un comté traditionnelle qui fait
de plus en plus défaut dans les autres
sites de montagne
ici on se marie encore en costume local
et pas toujours pour les besoins de la
caméra l'été quand la neige a fondu et
quand les touristes sont partis les
valoir un cultivent la terre font de
l'élevage ou bien construisent des
maisons voire des immeubles al'approche
de l'hiver les vaches rentra les tables
lemasson troque le bleu de chauffe
contre la panoplie de moniteur de ski
tout le monde met la main à la neige
les 900 habitants de valloire saft aussi
exploiter les vacances des autres
vous vivez bien en bonne entente avec
les touristes qui veulent bien sûr le
terme aux attentes
on est amis alors dissous et ses forces
mais est-ce que ça nuit pas un peu au
côté traditionnel nos orientations de la
première génération valloire a connu les
premiers balbutiements des sports
d'hiver c'était en 1930
avant cette date les jeunes partaient
vivre en plein ils sont maintenant
revenus au pays
valloire est habité par environ 900
habitants je dirais que 885 sont nés
dans le pays
voilà pourquoi c'est une station village
d'une authentique station village tuer
le cochon à la ferme
aujourd'hui en dehors des abattoirs il
faut bien les chercher les villages où
cela se pratique encore en pleine saison
la capacité d'accueil est de 8000 lit le
ski ici c'est 50 % seulement des
finances de la commune pour l'instant
l'équilibré bon mais il faut endiguer la
sortie de terre des immeubles le jour où
ces immeubles auront remplacé les
chalets ce jour là les stations villages
auront perdu ce qui fait depuis toujours
leur succès mais le gros risque c'est
que justement les promoteurs qui ne sont
là que pour un temps donné très peu de
temps construit d'une façon anarchique
fasse monter le coût des terrains à tel
point que les habitants du village ne
puisse plus même faire leur vie l'art ne
puisse plus faire leur chalet dans
lequel ils vont vivre eux et leurs
familles parce que les propositions des
promoteurs sont telles que les modestes
joint du pays n'arrive plus acheter des
terrains au prix proposé par les
promoteurs nous évalue le terrain à
disque admis à l'hectare c'est à dire le
prix de la construction rida
construction ne veut pas entendre parler
des terres agricoles et comment vous
faites pour vous en sortir
et bien justement maintenant on est en
bagarre avec le fisc besoin qu'est ce
que vous allez pouvoir continuer ce
combat là ce régime là il y aura plus
personne pour s installer un même nous
je passerai offert à valoir comme aux
jets aux contamines ou à saint maurice
la lutte contre le béton est maintenant
engagé une bataille qui est loin d'être
gagné
voilà point final de ce journal vous
retrouverez hervé claude vers 22h45 pour
la dernière édition
du journal d'antenne 2 philippe
harrouard demain pour les éditions du
week-end et bien sûr patrick poivre
d'arvor dès la semaine prochaine pour le
journal de 20h je me retire sur la
pointe des pieds
très belle soirée